hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing under Olaf whatever what is he
going to do
hey let's play a Catalan oh it's a bit
hot going to a tower in this more water
what what is that so it's just gifting
me upon this for absolutely nothing or
what kind of an opening is that really
weird okay so what now if I trade he's
got if he's got some development it's
got some development but I cannot quite
believe it
and it cannot be enough it's not it's
not like it's no compensation is a
little bit this practice got like three
Tempe or so interesting okay so he's got
ninety four as a possibility maybe this
one no
if Aiko Bishop she twists got 94
amazingly
hmm remarkable
yes he's got very very decent
compensation now and crime if I go III
my light squeeze really really suck okay
so
yeah I saw that but I don't think it's
such a big issue
I can Knight c3 I can I can develop 93
before H was something like that
[Music]
yeah 1994 is a problem and h3 is like
the the slowest move ever
[Music]
yeah but 94 is a big threat so just what
it is
Wow
couldn't take because of roopd one made
I have the most unnatural position ever
with record everything it looks
completely ridiculous
maybe I can can consolidate this somehow
at some anything but from 93 route g7
shoot yeah it's it's really really an
odd position
you know maybe I'm maybe I'm okay
you know I'm okay I'm not getting
checkmated or anything
my rooks are perfectly placed down so
what what kind of I mean I'm sorry to be
so frank but blacks opening issues it's
just ridiculous it should not work what
did I do wrong huh the engine doesn't
even dislike it so much that is crazy
this is just not that it is not an
opening line that has ever seen you can
do that that's crazy
so I have to take it back it's not
totally ridiculous yeah maybe maybe a a3
is badger the engine just wants to play
Bishop g2 of course I was afraid of this
move but I seem to have just 93
now the thing is I can simply give that
up it's not a big problem so let's say
it takes this and I'm just playing this
position with ideas like that I have a
good Bishop yeah probably even though
it's just like an engine just gives 0.5
or 0.4 here that's not a lot but after
this I'm really into trouble I'm really
in trouble bishop d5 is very strong and
now I'm not my position looks really
ridiculous this this I think that was
the relatively best I'm not I'm actually
not that unhappy with my defense I felt
it was kind of okay Knight f3 now or III
yeah I was
III I couldn't quite with e3 yeah I felt
like this this could be some Knight g4
business that somebody I could have
three but something like in Knight to e5
looks terrible okay I went here Bishop
see tool and yeah and now I'm sitting in
this position really on Bishop c5 age
three yeah
it's ultra slow at the bishop d4 now is
strong but even after castles I'm kind
of I'm in a bind here 96 better him
something like that would have happened
and then probably just centralize
I mean I think my position is just
ridiculously the bad you cannot move
anything yeah he captured and here I
felt I'm somewhat out of the woods at
least I'm not losing immediately YUM so
at five I will be shipped g5 that was a
that was winning immediately okay lads I
should have seen that it's a double
attack hmm
that was stupid now I'm not better
anymore not better I mean I'm okay but
I'm not not better and roughly here I
felt like it's switching now it has
switched to my favor hook c3 is good you
know you can go with the king as I did I
think this is just wrong yeah I mean
okay it does not have to resign and
still fight but I'm winning b6 and I
probably have a winning advantage that
was still a bit a bit of an odd game I
thought that opening was really really
really ridiculous but it's not totally
stupid
taketake but should be should be -
probably then YUM this is probably what
refutes the whole thing if you if night
before it's not a problem then this is
strong now that that's a thing okay yes
other thanks for watching